dr max wir haben jetzt schon länger
darüber gesprochen markus söder das wort
rasch gerade verwendet meinte damit aber
eigentlich nur die verlegung von
patienten was de facto keine triage ist
aber trotzdem wie aktuell wie akut ist
die situation momentan auf deutsche
intensivstation was können sie uns dazu
sagen wie nah sind wir tatsächlich an
szenarien wie in bergamo dran
ja ich kann erstmal beruhigen die
intensivstation sind schon sehr gefüllt
und wir haben ja jetzt 4491 cupid 19
hinzu unser normalen intensiv was ihn
zusätzlich die wir versorgen ist das ist
schon eine starke belastung aber wir
haben ja immer noch viele tausend betten
als notreserve zur verfügung die wir
dann auch anschalten könnten wenn es
jetzt immer immer mehr beenden werden
das heißt bevor ist in deutschland ein
trauerspiel davon sind wir noch sehr
sehr weit und er hat ich persönlich gehe
davon aus dass wir heute beschlüsse von
der bundesregierung und in
ministerpräsidentin ministerpräsidenten
bekommen und deswegen gehe ich davon aus
dass es keine tricks situation in
deutschland geben wird
das sind erstmal auf jeden fall gute
nachrichten trotzdem natürlich
intensivstationen sind mit der grund
warum wir jetzt in diesen plan hat
doktor komm um eben unser
gesundheitssystem hier in deutschland zu
schützen
die maßnahmen die jetzt gerade
beschlossen worden sind inwiefern
glauben sie sind diese ausreichend dafür
ich bin sehr froh dass diese maßnahmen
beschlossen worden sind weil wir werden
die sicherlich ein sicherlich eine
deutliche reduktion ich gehe davon aus
dass zu einer reduktion der neuen
sektion wird und damit auch zu einer
reduktion der neuaufnahmen von kuwait 19
patienten das ist auf jeden fall richtig
und wichtig dass jetzt vor weihnachten
hier entsprechen schon aktiv werden wir
wollen ihnen noch einmal zeigen was
markus söder gerade in der
pressekonferenz zur triage situation
gesagt hat konkret teilweise gibt es
schon triage in deutschland ich nehme
ich das man entscheidet wer behandelt
wird oder wer woanders sind verlegt
werden muss also teilweise gibt es schon
trias situationen und er hat es in
richtung verlegung begründet also dass
man verlegen muss
von einem krankenhaus ins andere
passiert das bereits bei ihnen auch
wissen sie davon fällen
und wo ist es momentan besonders schlimm
also bei uns passierte es nicht in dem
sinne dass wir von unserer klinik in
anderen ligen verlegen müssen sondern es
ist so dass wir patienten und einem
kleineren kader sind übernehmen und die
besonders schwere fälle versorgen das
war immer so und die die situation die
in dieser prinz oder angesprochen hat
ist wie sehen wir im moment gerade zum
beispiel in sachsen wo die kranken
wirklich sehr sehr voll sind und wo es
zumindestens jetzt schon überlegen und
gibt das man ebenfalls hier noch
tatsächlich in andere krankenhäuser
verlegen muss das ist in dem sinne aber
nicht die pace die wir eigentlich meint
reals heißt in unserem verständnis ja
erst wenn wir ein eine kapazität ein
bett und zwei patienten haben und hier
entscheiden müssen wer dieses bett und
diese intensiv medizin erhält
um es klar zu sagen so wie markus söder
das wort dort verwendet hat ist es
falsch das war das würde ich so nicht
sagen ich habe unser verständnis ist ein
anderes er hat das sicherlich so gemein
dass sozusagen kritisiert wird in dem
man sich entscheiden muss welcher
patient bleibt jetzt in dem ort a und
welcher muss auch b das sicherlich auch
in dem sinne auch eine entscheidung wo
man ja auch zwischen patienten
entscheiden muss also falsch ich jetzt
nicht sagen aber ich glaube wir müssen
vorsichtig sein mit der verwendung des
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren